iran
my question i guess is what is your view
on
the us's relationship with iran right
now especially like during the trump
era and where do you think it's going
right now with current politics with
joe biden potentially taking office
and uh where do you see us now and in
the future history of u.s iran relations
is is really a tragedy of of lost
opportunities
and misunderstandings to this day i
think iranians and americans
see that history in completely different
ways
they're like parallel train tracks our
two interpretations just
never coincide so from the american
standpoint u.s iran regulations
begin and end in 1980 1979
so that was the period when uh our shah
who had been our faithful ally for 25
years and who we had
installed on the peacock throne uh was
overthrown
and then our diplomats were taken
hostage this
started a cycle of bitterness against
iran
as far as we understood at the time
which was very little
those iranians who took our diplomats
hostage were nothing but
nihilistic savages who did this in
violation of
every law of god and man we
never stopped hating them for that
and since then we have been almost
without a break
in deep confrontation with iran
this is odd because
life in iran is so much more like life
in the united states than
uh in many of our so-called allies the
society in iran is
very much like ours whereas the society
in many of the countries in the middle
east that are our so-called
allies not like ours iran also has
uh long-term strategic goals that are
actually in many ways congruent with
ours
sunni extremism which we claim to be
fighting in the form of al-qaeda and ice
is the greatest enemy of iran
those extremists that we're fighting
that we claim to have as enemies
are their greatest enemy they want to
kill all shia
and iran is the center of shia islam so
iranians definitely have a
motivation intensely involved in the
anti-terror struggle
in the middle east so despite all of
this
the emotion that comes from the
overthrow of the shah and the hostage
crisis is still
reverberating through our politics and
it has been fanned by our so-called
friends in saudi arabia and israel
who for their own reasons are very
focused on the idea of containing
iran that's the way we see the
relationship
but there's a completely different
interpretation from the iranian side
so the iranians would tell you yeah
there was the hostage crisis that was
unfortunate but that was just a bump in
the road
the real moment when everything went bad
between the united states and iran
was in 1953
so this is an episode of which most
americans are
ignorant in in 1953
iran was emerging as an incipient
democracy
because it was democratic the government
responded to the demands of
the iranian people were all focused on
one issue and that was oil
iran is sitting on an ocean of oil the
oil was its own
one british company which in turn was
owned by the british government
at the same time iranians were living in
some of the worst conditions of anybody
in the world
it was only logical that when iran
finally moved into democracy in the
period after the second world war
the first thing a democratic government
would want to do is
take back control of the oil resource
and that's what it did
so prime minister maha sadek and the
iranian parliament
nationalized the iranian oil resource
that said in motion a series of events
that led the cia
and its british counterpart to overthrow
mosaddeq in 1953 that wasn't just the
overthrow of an individual
it was the end of democratic government
in iran
we reinstalled the shah on his peacock
throne
and he went on to rule with increasing
repression for another 25 years
that repression produced the explosion
of the late 1970s
what we call the islamic revolution and
that's what turned iran into the country
that it is today
being led by a clique of anti-american
mullahs it all started in 1953 this is
the iranian narrative
but in america we don't recognize that
we ever interfered and said everything
wrong there but the fact is this
if we had not intervened and overthrown
iran's democratic government in 1953
we might have had a functioning
democracy
in the heart of the muslim middle east
all these
70 years and i can hardly wrap my mind
around how different the world and the
middle east might be
if we had only decided to allow iranian
democracy to unfold
rather than react to crush it as a way
of
protecting our access to oil
now i mean recently just i think this
year it was either late 19 or early 2020
trump ordered the execution or had uh
that general solemn solomoni i believe
is how you say it
he was killed in a drone strike wha what
is your view
on that and what do you think his his
reasoning for that or his competence of
the whole situation was
again there's such a different narrative
from the iranian side and from the
american side
so the american narrative is
iran is a hegemonic power
it's trying to extend its tentacles all
around the middle east
it sponsors militias and political
groups and gives them money and weapons
suleimani the general who was the head
of the revolutionary guards
was seen as the person who was the
diabolical master of this network
with all its middle eastern tentacles
and therefore
a kind of terrorist mastermind uh
in the middle east terms anybody is a
terrorist
who opposes the interests of the united
states particularly with any violence so
um when you are uh militantly or
violently resisting
american power in the middle east that
that's what defines a terrorist
uh in our view so he became something
like the chief terrorist
now look at it differently from the
iranian side
so iran is the center of shia islam
shia islam is the number one enemy
of radical sunni movements
like al-qaeda and now isis those
groups have as i said earlier their
principle goal is to kill
all shia they want to come in iran and
essentially kill everyone in iran
that's who their real enemy is they hate
the shia more than they hate
christians or jews or anyone else um
naturally makes iran eager to fight
those groups
and mr general suleimani was definitely
the greatest
isis killer of all time we have been
even alive with al qaeda and its
brother groups in places like syria but
iran
never did that for reasons of
self-preservation
the other piece of the suleimani and
iranian
influence story is this
iran's is as i said the world center of
shiite islam
but there are pockets of shia shiaism
all over the middle east and beyond
uh in many places those people are the
oppressed if you go to a
muslim city there are middle east city
let's say like beirut
you'll find essentially the poor
neighborhoods those are the shia
neighborhoods
uh and social services
are very uh weak in from the government
there that's why
groups like hezbollah have grown up
they provide the whole network of social
services
that keep shia communities alive if a
widow
can't survive with their kids the
government has no programs for those
people but you can go to the hezbollah
office and they will help you it's a
kind of a
government shadow government those are
shia organizations and they're sponsored
by iran
those organizations also have military
wings as like hezbollah
so iran is thinking we are just
supporting oppressed
and persecuted shia communities all over
the middle east
it's not that we're trying to expand
influence it's we're trying to protect
our own people and so uh
again the narratives are so different
um i was quite taken aback by the
decision to kill
a suleimani um it certainly was
something that
bound iranians together again uh
everybody in iran i think admired him
for for what he had done
so it was definitely a symbol if one was
needed
as to how intensely the anti-iran hatred
is still
now a lot of the narrative from
trump's team and trump was that
soleimani was responsible for the deaths
of
tons and tons of u.s soldiers not tons
but lots of u.s soldiers
um and attacks on u.s bases over there
are you suleimani was supporting militia
groups
right in play in iraq um and those
militia groups
were devoted to pushing the united
states
out of iraq don't forget that iraq is
also a majority
shia country uh
most of the leaders of iraq are people
who
during the sundown to go to live
iran because they were shia they
couldn't survive under so
these are with very deep ties to iran
this
very strong tie between iran and iraq
that has to do with the shia
majorities in both countries so yes
iran was supporting militias
that were attacking american soldiers in
iraq and their answer would be well you
shouldn't be here that's why we attacked
you we attacked invaders
in our part of the world but of course
from the point of view of the united
states
anybody who attacks american soldiers is
a terrorist
and if suleimani was even indirectly
connected to those attacks that could
have put him high on our death list
you